Do you want to use your time,
speaking time?
There are no more words to speak
about what's going on in Resso,
Mr President
of this session.
There are no more laws to break.
There are no more
appeals that we can do to what's going on.
The hypocrisy is obvious.
Our collective humane has failed.
We said that we won't fail,
but we're failing again.
Human rights have a skin colour.
And the darker you are,
the less human rights you have.
We have been tried to be silenced.
They have tried to make us look like antisemite.
They have tried to make us look like
we don't care about the safety of the Israeli people.
All of that
still to make it possible to kill more Palestinians,
unfortunately.